[Applause]
every season activists a great actress
the star of ABC's scandal emmy-nominated
is both actress and producer of the HBO
movie confirmation Kerry Washington
[Applause]
now you are you are with child oh yeah
I'm knocked up again
yeah not how far along is that cuz I
noticed you think you're hiding nothing
yeah we try to hide it on the show but
in real life there's no hope for right
so that's exciting yeah it is very
excited is it does it focus the mind you
think on what's going on with the nation
when you know that a little little child
of yours will be dealing with the
repercussions of whoever becomes
president yeah I mean I think you know
I've always been a fairly political
person and and mostly not because I'm in
the public eye but because I'm an
American and I think we have a right and
responsibility to participate in our
democracy so having a child might open
up my mind to the issues like this
ridiculous maternity leave the trumped
about just recently yes now if
you didn't catch this this week probably
because it Kellyanne I mean she's good
or his daughter who's also great and I
think it's important that we not be
distracted by these very smart very
articulate beautiful women who work on
the Trump campaign who are a lot smarter
than the candidate I think rightly
should be not swaying right now because
they will not have their finger on the
button he will but but you're right
Kellyanne and his daughter got him this
week to reach out to women with a
maternity and child care plan which I
guess will be necessary he's gonna
deport all the nannies but
but why do you why do you say it's
ridiculous I mean I think there's been a
lot of talk about it being insulting to
women but I think it's actually
insulting to families and to workers
because there's no paternity leave
there's no family leave like for Hillary
Clinton these issues these policies are
not about women's policy this is about
economic policy because we understand in
this country that if families are able
to take care of each other we do better
as a nation I choose that candidate over
the guy who brags about how they never
changed a diaper we've literally brags
about how we never changed a diaper I
think that's crazy but also there's no
way to pay for it in his plan no really
it's logistical II right it's not about
fraud which they all say when they don't
want to pay for so we know a year ago he
talked about these help these child care
plans that his company had trumpet ears
and Trump kids that were supposed to be
these great plans for people who worked
for him they did a little digging cuz he
talked about the the cocktails that the
kiddie cocktails and coloring books and
the slides they did research that wasn't
for his workers that was for people who
were guests at his fancy hotels and he
didn't apparently understand the
distinction well he doesn't give his
workers were like if we have child care
we don't know about it he doesn't he
doesn't give money to his own charity
it's the Trump foundation he hasn't put
a dime in since 2008 and then he gives
money to other charities from history
asks people to give him money to give to
charity right they think it's from him
and it's not okay enough I certainly
don't want to be on Donald
Trump
just kidding Griego believe me there's
plenty more
but let's talk about our girl because
there is a real enthusiasm gap I read it
today it was a very scary numbers I
don't know where I have them but
something like Millennials are you still
a millennial you're on the edge of the
Millennial are sure my agent 100 who say
yeah I think you are okay yeah / and it
is you um and she dipped something like
in pregnancy on the rise no but she's
she's way down with the Millennials they
have fallen off the wagon not doing
there's a big enthusiasm gap they say
with black and Hispanics but I don't
count
well I'm black I'm like this yes I think
you can I understand what you're saying
I I think there's a bigger problem which
is that right now we are in a political
climate where we are being led by the
media no offence to vote for the loudest
candidate and the meanest the bulliest
candidate in the playground and that we
are voting based on a cult of
personality or cult of celebrity rather
than voting in our best interest I think
if we really look at policy voting for
Trump is voting against our best
interests as Americans as workers as
people of color as women voting not
voting is voting against ourselves so
voting for Trump is voting against
ourselves not voting as one against
ourselves and I think in this election
voting for a third party candidate is
voting against our nose now I agree
there
and a lot of people say like what she
doesn't have policy she doesn't address
the issues that are important to us but
I think that's because the noise again
is coming from the bully in the
playground if you do the research the
policy is there with Kelly Ann again
Kelly Ann's really good at what she does
really playing Olivia Pope I know spin
when I see it she's right what she's
doing really right I mean the very first
speech she gave after announcing her
candidacy was about criminal justice
reform so when people of color when
young people are out there saying she's
not doing enough for us like we have to
do the work to dig because the media is
not spoon-feeding us the information we
need vote in our bargain Dorothy that's
right I mean here's why I have no faith
in the outcome I saw Trump was in Flint
Michigan this week okay and I saw this
woman that they interviewed and you know
the reporter said Donald Trump came here
do you think he means it he's gonna help
I don't know they said what but Hillary
came here months ago and the woman said
yeah but that's when all the media was
here maybe she was just trying to glom
onto that so you know I feel bad for
these people in Flint but on the other
hand if you don't want your kids
poisoned that's right maybe do a little
research because on one hand you have a
guy who's never been to Flint never
showed the least bit of concern care
empathy for anything about poor people
their communities only cares about the
rich and the yacht's his own
self-interest and his own self-interest
and then this other person who has
dedicated her life to it is just like
this versus the guy from the party who
did the problem to begin with who wants
to eliminate the EPA who wants to gut
regulations and cut taxes on the rich
and you can't figure out who to vote for
and nothing I feel bad for you but not
100% and when people talked about her
long history there may be things that
you don't particularly agree with at
some point like I know a lot of people
of color and Millennials talk about her
position on criminal justice reform and
the super predator stuff and I hear that
and I understand it I would rather vote
for the candidate who is willing to
address mistakes address issues take
responsibility be accountable be a part
of a change solution rather than the
candidate who chooses to continue to
perpetuate fear and hate
in the present and this is the yeah this
is a big problem I have with liberals
cleaning up a little spot over here when
there's a giant pile of on the
other side of the room
you